most children in the flood-affected
silhouette region returned to class on
july the 19th but for some getting to
school isn't easy ferzana akhtar and her
schoolmates had to take a boat on their
first day back
i'm
today is the first day we are going to
school as our homes were damaged and
partly submerged by the flooding it's
still difficult because of the remaining
water in the area
the u.n estimates nearly 20 000 people
including 3 000 children are still
living in temporary shelters
this school was used as a shelter aside
from people livestock was also kept here
so we had to clean up the entire place
before reopening
only around 30 to 40 percent of students
have returned to the school
the government said it's already made
plans to provide new books and
educational materials
more than 400 educational institutions
in the region were used as shelters
since the flood waters receded we've
been able to reopen most of the schools
this week
some people have returned home and are
trying to repair the damage
water points and legend needs to be
repaired and communication is still very
difficult as flood water in many places
have not totally receded yet
and their family are rice farmers
they're worried about their future as
they have no other source of income
there was so much stuff i had all washed
away i barely survived my husband had to
break the wall to rescue me from inside
the house which was completely flooded
ramiz's eight-year-old daughter thani is
anxious to return to school
my children's education is tall because
there's still water around our home the
roads are muddy full of sludge we don't
have a boat a government climate action
policy due to be launched ahead of the
cop27 conference in november suggest any
new developments to be built using water
resistant construction materials
but for the families who have lost
everything it will take months if not
years to rebuild their homes and they
need all the assistance they can get
tanvi chaudhary al-jazeera select
bangladesh